Syrian president Basha al-assad is being
welcomed back into the fold of some Arab
Nations after having been summoned by
most world leaders for more than a
decade
it's brutal cracked out on
anti-government protests in 2011
triggered a civil war that's still going
on
the conflicts led to sanctions against
the Syrian governments by its neighbors
and Western Nations but in recent weeks
fueled by a devastating earthquake Assad
has been rebuilding diplomatic ties and
asking for economic reprieve from
walking the red carpets in Oman to
meeting Egypt's foreign minister
here's how Assad has shifted His Image
and what it means for the Middle East
a devastating earthquake hits turkey and
Syria in February While most of the
casualties were in Turkey more than 6
000 died in Syria Assad's government set
Western sanctions from the war hampered
its rescue efforts within hours of the
earthquake taking place there was a
meeting of top level Syrian officials in
Damascus and the idea was now we're
gonna leverage this at two level the
first one lobby against sanctions for
the end of sanctions not just exemptions
and two we're going to use it as a tool
to sort of get our Arab neighbors or
other Arab countries to get closer to us
the earthquake appears to have given a
sad momentum as he seeks to capitalize
on the humanitarian disaster to reduce
his isolation
in the days following the disaster
representative of some countries
including the United Arab Emirates Egypt
and Jordan visited Syria so really you
could see that war was already ongoing
as a represhment sort of accelerated at
that stage Assad also made only his
second state visit since 2011 to Oman a
country that never broke ties with
Damascus European and Arab officials
said Syria's president used the trip to
lobby for the removal of Western
sanctions in return for keeping
Crossings into rebel-held areas in Syria
open
Assad's efforts to restore ties have
been building since the Arab League a
group of 22 Nations suspended Syria when
War break out in 2011.
in the past few years the Syrian leader
has beat back Rebels with the help of
Russia and Iran both countries remain
key Partners to the regime
Assad arrived in Moscow in March to hold
talks with President Vladimir Putin to
develop cooperation between the two
countries
and Syria has been working with its
neighbors to curb the rise of terrorist
groups and the trade in the illicit drug
capital
for a number of countries in the region
there were already some kind of
conversation on counterterrorism
obviously because of the presence of the
Islamic State you know and other groups
you know Affiliated or close to Al-Qaeda
so that was always some very sort of
discreet engagement that accelerated
because of katagon because of this
illicit drug that started really to
flood the region from Syria into
countries like Egypt Saudi Arabia the
UAE and Jordan
now a deal is being brokered between
Assad and some Arab Nations including
Jordan to help Syria more formally
reintegrate it could benefit the region
for a number of reasons the prime
concept is really stability if you have
a country in the region that is um where
there's no rule of law and everything is
sort of collapsed like we had at times
you know in Somalia or in Libya it has
implications for the rest of the region
and that's what they want to avoid I
think they want to avoid another Libya
somalia's central government has
struggled for more than a decade to
contain terrorist attacks from the
al-Qaeda linked group al-shabab Libya
has been in turmoil since long time
leader muammakadafi was overthrown in
2011.
for Syria all of Hassan's diplomatic
efforts come against the backdrop of the
long drawn-out Civil War which has
spanned over 12 years
hundreds of thousands of people have
died and the conflicts created the
world's largest Refugee crisis according
to the United Nations but even as the
war continues and Arab countries bring
Assad back into the fold convincing the
West to ease tensions will be more
difficult the ascensions program which
are not ready again under this scenario
to to end would be potentially an
impediment for our personal
while the UN set the status quo of
isolating Syria cannot continue there
needs to be a coordinated International
effort in support of this with all key
players working in the coherent effort